welcome to Horace house the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and da Vinci newest tech products today
we're taking a look at how rising CPUs
are so cheap but before we delve into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to stay updated
with the latest tech news related to
gaming and pcs so AMD rising CPUs have
always offered incredible value with not
only high core care CPUs at a cheap
price but also really great stock
coolers that easy explanation for this
was that Intel has just been completely
ripping us off for the last couple of
years and Amy just cut down their profit
margins in order to make this happen
however recently Andy just announced her
new 2990 X which is going to come with
32 cores and 64 threads and it's
speculated price is $1,500 now I know
that this is just a speculation but
knowing AMD I think this will actually
come true so that really raises the
question how is AMD able to offer such
high korkin CPUs for such a low price in
toes 18 core CPU costs $2,000 so AMD is
literally almost offering double the
amount of cores and threads for 500
dollars cheaper there's no way that AMD
could pull all this off with just lower
profit margins could they they must have
a big secret that allows them to offer
such high core count CPUs for a low
price
right well the first thing that I
thought of was that maybe the production
process for rising CPUs is a lot cheaper
than Intel because AMD may be employing
better and more efficient production
processes and using less quality
materials which are cheaper the thing is
is that AMD's die size is usually bigger
than its Intel counterparts it can't
really skimp out on cheap silicon while
making CPUs and as a result MD is not
saving money by using less materials or
worse quality materials either
however aim D does employ infinity
fabric technology which makes developing
and making high core count CPUs a lot
easier so what they do is that
take a bunch of modules which each have
four cores each and is put it together
and make hike or concieve use like
thread ripper this would save a great
sum of money when AMD is trying to
develop and research new CPUs and upping
their core count because each time they
aren't starting from scratch they
already have those modules to work on
and they just have to fix the little
bugs that may arise and this is why AMD
is able to up the core count so much
year after year from 16 just last year
all the way to 32 so infinity fabric
technology definitely plays a crucial
role in how AMD is able to continuously
bring out new and higher core count CPUs
and not much more expensive prices the
development and research process of new
high court count CPUs for AMD is a lot
lot cheaper because of infinity fabric
technology but that really only applies
to high Corky on CPUs like rising seven
and mostly for thread Ripper so well
maybe into markets a lot more and spends
a lot more on operating costs because of
that well this doesn't really make sense
either because AMD has only been
competitive for a little over a year now
and so amy has to really market in order
for their new products to be recognized
by the public and as a result AMD's
marketing cost would probably be a lot
higher than into's on top of this
they're even giving away flagship CPUs
in order to improve brand recognition
for example md gave away 40 1950 x's to
8086 k owners for free
that itself is forty thousand dollars in
lost revenue so as you guys can see the
operating and marketing cost for AMD is
probably a lot higher than Intel because
of what the aggressive marketing they
have to do in order to become recognized
by the public and as for research and
development costs those would be a lot
higher for AMD as well because in to has
just really been sitting back and adding
a couple of gigahertz to their CPUs year
after year AMD on the other hand has
been making huge strides every single
year and therefore their research and
development cost would most likely be a
lot higher and finally you come back to
first point of this video which is
and he just cuts their profit margins in
order to be able to offer their CPUs for
a much lower price in tow and when you
really dove into it and do some more
research you realize that this is
precisely what is happening right now
intel has just been ripping us off for
so long by such a high profit margin now
we didn't even realize that CPUs can be
offered for such low prices aim East
gross profit margin for their first
quarter of this year was thirty six
point two five percent into on the other
hand had a gross profit margin of sixty
point five seven percent as it is
evident Intel is just highly over
pricing their CPUs and there really is
nothing much to it
Intel has just built up a really good
name over the past decade and they're
really just a market Dominator and for
the average consumer who makes up over
90 percent of PC purchases they usually
just buy pre bills and they buy what
they always bought which is Intel most
people just don't want to try something
new or think that Rison is a scam just
because of how cheap it is or they
simply just think that Intel has the
best performance whatever the case most
average consumers just stick to Intel as
a result Intel has built up a great
recurring buyer audience and therefore
they can charge whatever they want AMD
on the other hand is trying to capture
the educated buyer market by offering
really good value with their CPUs and
infinity fabric really helps them with
their high court councii P use and ask
for the extremely cheap prices that is
mostly accomplished by AMD HS cutting
their own profit margins for our benefit
so us educated buyers should support AMD
and biner cpus so that a couple of years
and D will become a much more popular
brand among the average consumer and
Intel would be forced to charge less so
there really is no secret to it aim D
just sacrificing their own profit margin
in order to offer really attractive
pricing so how do you guys feel about
this do you think that everyone should
support AMD and how do you feel about
being ripped off by Intel for so long
make sure to comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also you
guys like this video that makes your
jump a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to see more
videos just like this one but until next
time bye
[Music]